hello and welcome to Edinburgh where
tonight the three candidates battling to
be the snp's next leader and Scotland's
fast Minister will set out their case
I'm Beth Rigby this is Sky News and this
is Scotland's leadership debate
[Music]
we're here on the banks of the river
fourth in a building that has stood
since 1707 the same year as the act of
the Union between Scotland and England
this evening we have three candidates
who want to sever that Union and restore
Scotland's Independence
the vote to choose Scotland's next
leader opened at midday today the
candidates have been campaigning and
debating for weeks now it's decision
time for SNP members but it's not just
about them it's about all of us the
winner will lead a government in
Edinburgh that faces the cost of living
crisis and an NHS under strain and what
happens here could change the future not
just of Scotland but the entire UK so
let's hear from them Ash Regan Kate
Forbes and Hamza Yusuf tell us why you
have got what it takes to be Scotland's
next leader I'll start with you Ash
I am the candidate for getting
Independence done I am the only
candidate with a published plan on
legally achieving Independence
and I am the only candidate with a
published plan for what to do if
Westminster says no
and I am the only candidate with a plan
to improve the SNP
and I'm the only candidate who has
already reached out and is uniting the
wider YES Movement
if you want independence I am your only
hope
Forbes thanks Beth well tonight I want
to offer a fresh Vision to Scotland
because continuity won't cut it if
elected first Minister I want to reach
across the divide and persuade no voters
to vote Yes in a future referendum I
want to put economic growth front and
center not just as part of how we govern
now to tackle the cost of living crisis
and to reinvest in our public services
but also to make the economic case for
Independence and Paul after Paul shows
that I'm the most trusted to govern
Scotland well and to govern for all of
Scotland
I'll see you sir
good evening I'm Hamza Yusuf and I'm
asking our SMP members to make me their
first choice for first Minister I want
to build on that winning formula that
has seen us win election after election
that radical that Progressive agenda
which has seen success for the SNP grow
to unprecedented Heights I will build a
team that will deliver Independence so
the voice of the Scottish people can no
longer be denied I won't just look to
build an economic growth I'll put the
well-being economy at the center of my
plan so that the economy works for us
the people not the other way around I'm
the only candidate who will stand up to
westminster's paragraphs and maintain
that Pro and defendant's majority okay
in Hollywood so I'm asking you to make
me Hamza your first choice for first
Minister thank you to the three of you
now those are the last speeches we'll
hear tonight now it's time for some
answers and one of the big Battlegrounds
in this leadership contest is over in
pendants
an exclusive poll conducted by yougov
for Sky News has found that when you
exclude people who don't know or would
not vote 46 of people think Scotland
should be an independent country 54 said
they would vote no so let's start with a
question that was actually sent To Us by
a viewer I like this one it's Bruce
Lucas and his question is in the list of
priorities where does the question of
Independence sit and I'll kick off with
you please Ash
well for me Independence is a key
question because
um Scotland is actually as part of the
UK is suffering I would say
disproportionately as a result of being
part of the UK If you think about brexit
you know Scotland was dragged out of the
EU against our will and the hard brexit
that we've got as part of the UK has
having a disproportionately harsh impact
on Scotland we also have a cost of
living crisis again driven by
Westminster and high energy costs people
in Scotland are struggling right now and
for me one of the reasons to become
independent is because that is the way
we'll be able to solve some of these
problems for people at the moment under
Devolution it always feels like we're
fighting things with one hand tied
behind our back prior to view Kate
Forbes well quite clearly the people's
priorities right now are cost of living
and our public services reinvesting in
the NHS for example but for me
Independence has always been about a
means to an end so in a country which is
rich in energy why are people struggling
to pay their bills it doesn't add up and
the reason is that power is so far
removed from the people so Independence
is a means to an end but yes the next
first minister is going to have to
govern well they're going to have to be
trusted to deliver on the NHS
eradicating poverty and tackling the
cost of living crisis and those would be
my priorities Independence is the golden
threat that runs through everything we
do we have a Tory cost of living crisis
with Independence we don't just have to
replace one Tory government with a pair
limitation of a touring government we
can get rid of Tory governments forever
because they know they have never won an
election in the last 50 almost 60 years
here in Scotland so yes we will invest
in our public services but we can't do
that while the Tories continue their
austerity agenda so Independence just to
help us invest in those publics just
because one answer one one answer like
top priority yes or no it's the priority
for Scotland because it's how we're
going to deal with the challenges that
Scotland faces yes but as first Minister
I will make sure it's my priority to
work on the issues that are important to
the people of Scotland that's things
like the NHS the cost of living crisis
it's not your top priority good
governance is my top priority including
my delivering Independence yes
Independence is my top priority because
it helps us to resolve the challenges
we're facing with our public so that's
that's interesting because of all three
candidates you have been the person if
you like who has said repeatedly that
it's going to take a long time and that
you have to build sustained support and
action
in the past I've said Independence
down the road but now you're saying it's
your top priority that's that's not
correct at all in fact I was asked this
question on Sunday I know it was a rival
television channel but I said that
Independence is coming is inevitable
we're at that Tipping Point in fact but
what we have to do to win independence
is build that consistent majority
support we're close but it's going to
take a leader who can inspire people
with that Progressive vision and grow
support for Independence hey folks do
you think Scotland will be an
independent country in three years time
I would hope so yes you hope so Ash
Reagan with my plan Scotland will be an
independent country in three years time
okay so with your planet will be Kate
you hope so I'm to Yusuf okay it's going
to be independent in a few years time
but it's going to require us to build
that consistent majority support for
Independence it's interesting because
our poll found that 52 of respondents
don't think Independence will happen in
10 years time and only 30 percent would
what do you make of that case
we need to reset the discussion because
we've been fixated over a process rather
than making the case for Independence
this election is fascinating because
whilst we're appealing to SMP voters and
members we really need to be on the
front foot in persuading no voters to
vote yes that's what your polling shows
your polling shows that we need to do
more to persuade no voters to vote Yes
so we need a leader that can reach out
and certainly the polling illustrates
that I can do that the Battleground is
the economy the Battleground is where we
need to make an economic case and it's
not just about abstract political
arguments it's about illustrating and
demonstrating how Scotland truly can be
wealthier fairer and Greener because of
other countries the same size as
Scotland without our natural resources
can be wealthier than why can't Scotland
okay ashrigan what do you make of that
when people say a decade ago it's not
going to happen well I think it is going
to happen I think there is a demand from
the Scottish people I think that the SNP
hasn't been focusing on making the case
for Independence recently and with me as
leader that would change and I also
think that the s p government has lost
its way a little bit on some key issues
recently which has led to the public
having a perception that perhaps we're
not focusing on the issues that are
important to them so under my leadership
I will as first Minister focus on the
issues are important to the people of
Scotland I will set the independence
movement free because rightly that
should be out in Civil Society as part
of the wider movement and I will set up
a commission to build the infrastructure
for Independence so that gets Scotland
ready to become an independent okay okay
well look that's independence I'm sure
we'll discuss it discuss it more as the
evening goes along but now we're going
to do something a bit different because
I'm going to ask each candidate some
straight questions and I'm looking for
straight answers and then we're going to
open it up to their leadership Rivals
now before we came on air we drew lots
to decide who would go fast and the
person who drew the Short Straw is Ash
Regan ashrigan if you just could come
forward for me now according to our poll
nearly three times as many Scots think
you would be a bad first Minister rather
than a good one
and here's why 17 think you are
competent 24 think you are incompetent
and there's a lot of don't knows 13
think you're trustworthy versus 26 who
think you are on trustworthy so Ash
Regan right now it seems that the public
aren't sure or don't think you're up to
the job and the polling does show that
you are far behind your Rivals you've
never served in cabinet uh so I start
with a simple question for you really
can a rookie walk straight into the
office of fast Minister I'm far from a
rookie I've been in government for
nearly five years I think it is fair to
say though that in terms of name
recognition I'm definitely before now
was definitely um less well known than
the other two candidates I don't think
um really being a good first Minister
has got anything to do with how well
known you are and it's about whether
people can trust you whether you have
confidence in your abilities to deliver
whether you can build a team and whether
you have a plan for doing things which I
a plan for how we get independence and
it's also about competence isn't it and
being able to execute plans now you've
walked I what I would like you to do is
you you've talked about getting a
Scottish currency within quote a couple
of months of Independence quite
ambitious plan and it's really important
because obviously it's the economy it's
people's savings it's how everything
works so can you explain to me here in
as much detail as you'd like about how
you do that sure so we have a Scottish
currency group in Scotland which has
senior bankers and Senior economists on
it and there's many members of the s p
as part of that group and in 2014
currency and whether or not Scotland
could use the pound or whether they
should have their own currency was a key
Battleground as an issue in 2014 for the
yes campaign and I felt that we didn't
make the case adequately enough on that
point so my suggestion this time is that
using the commission one of the tasks of
the commission will be to set up the
infrastructure and clearly currency
would be a key part of that and my
currency plans have been supported by a
senior Economist who wrote in the times
just last week saying and he'd advised
the World Bank and other countries on
setting up central banks saying he
backed my plan for currency and I was
slightly misquoted in the time frame
what I said was we would do everything
that we can do Under The Evolution to
get ready but there were some things
that we'll have to do during the
negotiation period because that could
take some time so it's not going to take
once we become independent we would
transition within a couple of months but
no setting up a central bank and your
currency usually takes somewhere between
two and three years in total what I'm
saying is if we start the work now by
the time we become independent we'd be
able to transition sorry a couple of
years well it will but if we start now
before we're independent we build the
infrastructure now and then there's the
negotiation period where we talk with um
the UK government to decide on how what
the settlement is between Scotland and
the UK and then once we become
independent we move smoothly over to the
new currency this is very normal lots of
other countries have done it lots of
other new European countries have set up
currencies and transitioned within a few
months so you presumably going to set up
this this whole process as soon as you
become first Minister I'm going to start
work on that on the first day as first
month and what what institutions do you
need Ash Regan to set up a new currency
so you need a central bank and I'm going
to start all the planning and
preparation for that on the first day
that I get started and that will be part
of the commission so I'm suggesting that
we set up a commission which will plan
out all the Constitutions do you need to
set up
well that's um so the central bank and
then the currency
but you need other institutions to set
up
a currency so what are the other
institutions so I will take advice from
the very best bankers and economists and
um they will be doing that story so the
first Minister will not be involved in
this process this will be run by the
commission and it will be filled with uh
but but you you want to set up an
independence client so all I'm asking is
what other institutions do you need to
set up apart from the central bank
well that's the institutions you need
and the reason you need to do this is
because if we carry on down this road
and if we say that we're going to use
the pound Scotland is very exposed the
economy is very exposed we've seen that
in recent times with the pandemic so
what we've seen is that countries that
don't control their own currency had to
go to the IMF for a bailout so I would
say it's smart planning here this is a
credible plan to set up I can't give you
the full details on how it would work
yet because obviously we've got to go
through that process but what I'm saying
is I'm committed to doing this I think
it's the right plan for Scotland and
also it shows confidence that Scotland
could be independent because we're
beginning we're beginning to set up
those institutions it's just you may you
made
um Independence and a new currency a key
a key campaign now you're saying that
it's going to take two years no I said
I've always said that it would take that
time okay right that is the transition
time and you've talked about essential
about what about the other institutions
you need
what other institutions are you talking
about you don't know
the independent debt management office
right I'm sure as I said I don't have
full detail on this at the moment
because
um this is going to be the stuff that we
looked into by the commission and the
senior economists and bankers as a first
Minister you are surrounded by civil
servants you have top advisors that
would be able to advise you on this I
said very publicly right at the
beginning of this contest that being
able to set out a detailed policy
program in a week was an impossibility
so I am setting out some key lines here
which are the direction that I would go
in but I I'm quite upfront with you I
cannot fill in all the details at this
point okay
well that's thanks for clearing that up
about the timing but also
um you do need other institutions as I'm
sure your advisors will tell you another
critical policy area has been education
do you think that um you can hit the uh
Target to close the poverty related
attainment Gap by 2026. I would like to
think that we could I know we have done
some good work on that and we're
certainly getting more children from
deprived areas into universities we've
done some very good work with care
experienced children getting them into
positive destinations but I think there
is more that we can do yes I'm running
out of time so the thing that most
people also remember from your campaign
is your idea of an independence
thermometer to measure Readiness what is
it where will you put it and how big is
it going to be so that wasn't my idea
that was something that I'd heard other
groups talking about it but I think the
kernel of it is right so the idea is
that the commission will do the work the
preparation and the planning in order to
get Scotland ready but we need to and we
must communicate that progress that
readiness to the public so we just need
to have some way of communicating that
to the public perhaps it's an index
perhaps it's just information on a
website I don't know but it needs to be
communicated to the public but because
that is what will build confidence with
the public that Scotland has what it
takes and it's ready to become an
independent but not necessarily a
physical signature okay all right thank
you Ashley if you'd like to go back uh
well that was Ash Regan uh Kate Forbes
what did you think of that well I think
the challenge here is that the key part
when it comes to Independence is
ensuring that we've got a stable economy
and that's far more important than our
own currency in the first few days of
Independence and the reason that's
important is because with a prosperous
economy we can eradicate poverty we can
increase the tax base and ultimately get
the revenues that we need for our Public
Services
if you can't control your own monetary
policy you're taking an absolutely crazy
risk with the Scottish economy anyone
will tell you that but what's that you
don't have the ability to create
liquidity you can't manage your own
economy you've got no flexibility it's
very dangerous and risky but anyone will
tell you that it's a risky experiment
men on Scotland that you're proposing by
using the arguments the arguments on an
economy that will really persuade people
is the fact that Scotland can't afford
to be fair for example everyone knows
Scotland or to be independent that is
critical that Scotland can afford to be
a favor and that's part of tackling
poverty and my question would be what
powers of Independence would you use to
tackle poverty and make the case for
Independence in that way rather than
focusing purely on current yeah although
it's important I don't think that we
need to do that I think what we need to
do is we need to govern wisely because
that creates trust with the public and
we've we've known that and that has
worked very well for us in the past but
then what we need to do is we need to
set our credible plan for how we get
there and how Scotland will be
independent and we need to answer these
key questions where that were
Battlegrounds before and where we didn't
quite make the case I think if we can do
that we will almost certainly win people
over we're roughly 50 50 most of the
time the polls do go up and down at
times but roughly we're almost there and
if you think about where we set off
um you know in 2012 you know support for
Independence I think when that was first
meeting like 27 so to suggest that
there's an uphill battle to climb here I
think do you think that we have become
obsessed with process to the detriment
of making the economic case for
Independence I do I think we have
definitely taken our eye off ball in
terms of making that case for
Independence
um answering some of these questions
that people had people often had
concerns about independence and we need
to make a better case we need to make
people feel safe that they can they can
safely choose Independence and know that
their family will be looked after that
schools will be good so that the NHS
will be well run and so on but of course
because it's hamza's turn thanks uh Ash
you accept that there's other countries
in fact across the Irish sea that have
used the Sterling and then transitioned
to their own currency so it's not to say
that this isn't a tried and tested one
it comes out you've said yeah said that
my plan isn't credible but have you
looked at who's backing my plan to say
that it isn't credible means you haven't
even given a cursory look to the plan
the planning that's been done by senior
bankers and economists I have the vast
majority of economists say that you
cannot set up your own currency in this
space of a few months in fact you've
just contradicted yourself well unless
everybody else is hearing something else
Ash they are managed to contradict
yourself no I have never contradicted
myself I've been very here right from
the start that there would be a planning
period an infrastructure building period
and the two-month period that was quoted
was just for transition it was not
building the whole currency
I'm pleased onto the campaign you've
managed to clarify that's why I said
right at the beginning I said the second
thing I wanted to ask you was you seem
to want to set up a lot of commissions
a few commissions this one where you
want a lot of advisors to tell you what
you're suggesting that would go ahead
without being fine let me finish and not
not interrupt me because I didn't
interrupt you in your sport if you if
you want to set up a lot of commissions
to hear from advisors I don't think
there's anything wrong with that but on
the economy which is the one of the
biggest issues that we're facing the
cost of living crisis have you got a
single plan for the economy if you're
the first minister in two weeks time
because you haven't been able to clarify
of course detail of a single I've set
all my plans out
talk about infrastructure before
I was talking about roads building
projects I have been mothballs so
infrastructure is very important I was
the first candidate to talk about a plan
for housing well let's just stop and I
was the first candidate to talk about an
energy company an idea that I see youth
picked up through hearing me talk about
it over the last few weeks you hadn't
said that out before I was the first
person to set that out so what road
would you build and how much would it
cost so I've said you know we had
promised the people of the North and the
northeast of Scotland that we would dual
the A9 and the a96 and we haven't
completed on that one how much would
that cost yeah we are losing the trust
of people in the north of Scots
to try to get specifics make promises
you make a lot of promises huge deliver
on them sure
I hear you you make a lot of promises
without specific so you're with Julia 96
how much would it cost and when would
you get it done by so what I've said
what I've committed to is that within my
first 100 days I will set out a new plan
on how I'm going to deliver that and to
what timetable and how much it would
cost well it hasn't gone out to Tender
again yet so nobody knows how much it
would cost there's no possible way to
answer that question for anyone right
now um I think one of the issues that
was run into is the way that the
contracts are being put out to Tender I
think one issue might be if we can break
them down into much smaller bundles then
we might be able to get smaller and more
local contractors to come in and take
over some of that work at a
cost-effective level okay I'm gonna have
to wrap that up now because
it's Finance Minister Kate Forbes if you
could step to the podon now Kate Forbes
wants to be the candidate of change in
this election even suggesting that her
government's own record is mediocre just
over a quarter of people think you would
be a good first Minister but more than a
third think you do the job badly 37
think you're competent 20 think you're
incompetent thirty percent think you're
trustworthy versus 27 who think you are
untrustworthy it looks like Kate Force
when it comes to the public you're
coming out on top but you have alienated
some of your own members and I want to
come on to some of those issues but what
I want to start off with with you is
child poverty because you're making this
the corner sudden of your campaign
you've said it's disgraceful that one in
four children live in poverty in
Scotland I know part of the solution a
big part is to grow the economy so I
don't want to spend too much on that I
know that already but will you also some
Yusuf has done pledged to increase the
Scottish toll payment to 30 pounds I am
open to increasing the Scottish child
payment I think actually the biggest
question rather than giving an amount
right now is to understand the impact of
the cost of living crisis at the time of
the next budget because quite clearly
inflation is at an all-time high right
now it's starting to decline Bank of
England forecast that it will continue
to decline but we know that those deep
social inequalities are only going to be
exacerbated through and I'm certainly
open to it as one means of eradicating
child poverty certainly not the only
meme
child property is 24 it's as high as
when the s p came into Power 16 years
ago
indeed and we've obviously been through
10 years plus of austerity and we've
seen the the welfare system being
destroyed by the UK government we've
seen the impact of covid and the fact
that poverty is not just about poverty
of income or Poverty of warmth it's also
about poverty of loneliness and of love
and it's about reaching out into these
families and households to offer these
young people oh just to be just to be
concrete measures of talk about the cost
of living I mean you'll say now that you
will look at the 30 pounds you didn't
say that a while ago uh so now you've
slightly moved on that but the child
probably Action Group and 70 other
Charities and groups wrote to you and
other candidates this afternoon to say
it needs to go up to at least 40 pounds
a week by the end of the parliament will
you commit to that and I think I I'm
certainly open to it what I'm not going
to do is set budgets ahead of next year
because I think those budgets need to
reflect the challenges of attain the
Scottish payment is not the only way to
support these families so for example
fuel insecurity is massive and ensuring
the fuel and Security fund is also
expanded But ultimately what we need is
parents to be in Secure well-paid
employment because you've got mums with
two jobs who can't feed their kids okay
full so let's move to social issues
because it's dominated your campaign
because many feel that you are out of
touch and tune with modern Scotland
there will be unmarried couples with
kids watching this gay married couples
watching this thinking that you
disapprove of their lifestyle there's
the camera will you apologize for the
hurt you've caused some of your remarks
certainly don't disapprove whatsoever
what I have set out is that I will
defend as I have through successive
budgets the rates of everybody in
Scotland to live and to love without
harassment and fear I mean people like
you know there are people in my own
family and and I my job as an elected
representative is to represent everybody
without prejudice and to deliver for all
of Scotland right okay you'll say that
you will protect existing rights you say
that you'll seek to enhance the rights
of everybody the Scottish government's
committed to introducing legislation by
the end of the year on ending gay and
trans conversion practices if you're
first Minister will that legislation on
banning all conversion therapy go ahead
I've already stated that I think
conversion therapy is abhorrent that
coercion is abhorrent and that I will
continue to support and banning a
conversion therapy I made a you've made
a distinction about coercion just to be
clear
will you ban conversion therapy whether
by coercion or consent well I have said
that we're obviously not a really simple
industry but we've not legislated yet so
we've had the reports and I think it's
critical that I reflect and listen to
those reports okay and take that flip
right well I'll give you the I'll give
you the report because the detail on
this is really important the expert
Advisory Group on ending conversion
practices commissioned by the Scottish
government said this quote we are clear
that as they constitute a human rights
violation it is not possible for
individuals to genuinely consent to
conversion practices being carried out
against them so I ask you again will you
ban all conversion therapy be that
coercion or consent well and my
commitment to you is to look carefully
at that and to take the legislation
forward what I'm not going to do because
I don't think any government has done
that yet is to precede the normal
process of the legislation yeah it's I'm
just asking for a clear answer
is that I think conversion therapy is
abhorrent it doesn't have any place in
Scotland and the legislation must ensure
that it is targeted and ensure that it
takes that to be fully clear will you
commit to ensuring there are no
exemptions to a ban on consent or
anything that there is no exemptions to
ban in conversion therapy conversion
therapy full stop is abhorrent and so in
terms of the legislation that would be
introduced under my leadership it would
reflect the fact that conversion therapy
is a point right okay so you're saying
if someone buy consent wants to have
their sexuality changed you think that
they should be allowed to do that is
that an adjustment to think
or should be allowed to live freely as
they choose and I do not think that
there should be a that there should be
conversion therapy in existence in Scott
so do you think then a gay man adult man
if he wants therapy to change his
sexuality should that be allowed or not
well it's it's it's it's his choice and
but I do not think we should allow
conversions to their choice well
we should not allow conversion therapy
in Scotland
right you know just said it's his choice
and this is all about whether you're
going to balance no because because my
position on this is that people should
be allowed to live as they choose in a
free tolerant society and I think the
conversion therapy bill should reflect
that but you're also asking me this in
advance of the Parliamentary legislative
process proceeding we've had the
evidence we need to reflect on the
evidence and introduce a bill that
reflects that evidence okay all right
hateful thank you if you'd like to
return to a spot I'll start with you
hamster Yusuf what what questions do you
have following that sure uh thanks
amongst their s p supporters when we
started this race three weeks ago you
were ahead I'm now 19 points ahead in
terms of SMP supporters and you've gone
back into a negative rating I accept
that we have to reach out to no voters
but it's so so important isn't it that
we don't lose our own supporters and but
they were able to reach out and the way
we do that is by not abandoning our
Progressive agenda isn't that right well
I believe that we should serve all of
Scotland and I think it's probably my
Approach that means I continue to
outperform both yourself and Ash when it
comes to enjoying the trust of the
public enjoying the trust of the public
and indeed the the trust of SMP
supporters another poll out today we've
just heard the findings demonstrate once
again that it's my message of
introducing change that is cutting
through and if we want to win
independence we both agree it's
important to win elections but it's even
more important to win independence and
to do that we have to persuade those who
are as yet unpersuaded to our course
that's a very good point but we also
can't lose the support that we've got
and isn't the challenge isn't the reason
you're losing SMP support is because as
that exchange with birther Sean you're
not able to give a really straight
answer to a really straight question on
our Progressive agenda and that's going
to lose our support so you can you can
appeal to conservatives because of maybe
you can economic Vision that you've got
but you're not able to understand the
support that you've got I'm appealing to
labor that's what they're pulling into
they're losing support yes and labor on
the basis of progressivity being
speaking up for the voiceless ensuring
that we are Advocate poverty increasing
uh wages and terms and conditions for
our social security let me ask the
question a different way package of
appealing to voters who don't yet
support let me ask a question then in a
different way why do you think that you
now have a negative rating according to
Sky News Paul why do you think
supporters mine says 19 points ahead of
you because with those supporters of the
SNP vote who'd intend to vote for us in
the next Road election you've got a
negative rating I've got a positive
rating you know the reasons I don't
think that's where you're particularly
strong amongst the SNP members of the
momentum is not definitely not net
positive ratings I've actually got
higher net positive ratings than either
of the opposition leaders I'm
it's a really straight question why do
you think you've got a negative rating
amongst SMP supporters you had a
positive one Ministry I asked why you
didn't have any concerns you can ask the
question why are you doing
budgets I would rather you answer the
question as opposed you can ask me a
question I'm about to the only question
about the only poll that matters is of
course the one the SNP voters are
involved with today and it's my
impression that SMP voters want someone
who can win elections they want someone
who can deliver Independence they want
somebody who can govern well and on all
the calling that we've had okay I am
ahead when it comes to these key metrics
not with saps I need to bring Ashton now
Ash Reagan what what did you make of
Kate's remarks well I want to ask Kate
about her plan for how we get to
Independence so we've had the same
process that we've been going through
for the last few years where we've been
winning elections and we've been using
that to beg Westminster to give us a
referendum and you've said you'll repeat
that process why would you want to
repeat a failed strategy I am not going
to repeat a field strategy I think we
need a fundamental reset so I think
right now the approach needs to be very
intentional and very explicit in terms
of attracting new voters to vote for
Independence to do that we need to be on
the front foot I do not think there's
been enough work done on making the
economic case for Independence or having
answers and I also think that
fundamentally good governance is
political govern well earn trust and you
persuade people to vote for Independence
these are the things that we need to do
in the world to get serious and I think
that's right and I think we both agree
on that however this isn't Northern
Ireland so Northern Ireland does they
have a mechanism where if support Rises
to a certain amount there and they're
entitled to have a border poll we don't
have that mechanism here so just
building support which is obviously very
straight you know that's an obvious
route doesn't actually translate that
into any way to get a mechanism in order
to get to Independence so what would you
say to that the process I think almost
not quite takes care of itself when you
see that significant increase in support
foreign
Independence has shifted as
substantially as I would have liked or
indeed you would have liked despite the
fact that we've had brexit we've had the
cost of living crisis we've seen the UK
government trying to rule Devolution
that dial hasn't shifted enough and I
think it's because we haven't laid the
groundwork with the the economic case I
think it's because we haven't listened
to no voters and indeed dare I say it
respect
I would agree with all of that but I'm
still lacking an answer to the question
of what is the plan you know
Independence has been as high as 56 I
think in some polls consistently but
what will you do to translate that high
support other than begging Westminster
for a referendum well it certainly we
won't be going cap in hand but I think
we want to ensure that there is as much
support as possible not just because
that's a means to get independence but
also can you see why people would think
that there is no plan here there's no
there's nothing different
not quite because the plan right now the
plan to date has not shifted the dial as
substantially as it needs to and you
have obviously focused on process which
is quite right but it doesn't matter
what the process is if you don't
increase the support for Independence I
think we can do it but we need to get
serious about listening to No voters and
understanding why they still so you
think Scotland I'm going to have to wrap
it more quickly well I was going to ask
you as well do you think it's
hypocritical to be coming out and saying
that you'll give carers uh you know the
15 pounds an hour when you had the power
to do it of course not at all the reason
why it's not hypocritical is because the
only way to fund it is to realign
budgets right now we've got it hundreds
of millions of pounds being spent on
delayed discharge if we realign the
budget would you still delay discharge
we can pay our caters more so it's about
a realignment of budget okay okay folks
I'm gonna have to wrap it there
um now let's turn to you Hamza Yusuf the
health secretary has has who has said
he's happy to be labeled the continuity
candidate in this election now according
to our poll twice as many people think
you would be a bad first Minister as a
good one 22 of people think you are
competent forty percent think you're
incompetent only 18 think you're
trustworthy versus 42 who think you are
untrustworthy
that's pretty disappointing isn't it
well look I've had 10 and a half years
of having the most difficult and
toughest jobs in government but look at
this campaign I mean this campaign
started three weeks ago I've managed to
quadruple my some support amongst the
public when this campaign started I was
behind when it came to SNP supporters
I'm now 19 points ahead I've done that
in three weeks imagine what I'm able to
do in three months I'll be able to
inspire people with the vision that I've
got for a socially just Scotland and get
more and more support not just for the
SNP but for the cause of Independence
well you seem to be taking those rather
harsh pole pole uh decisions uh on the
chin but look let's let's talk about
that's because the momentum's with me
look at what's happening okay well
increase support well let's talk about
your portfolio NHS it's a top phase
priority I want to look at your record
as health Minister what's your target
for the number of patients who should be
seen in a e within four hours 95 of
course was the pre-pandemic Target and
of course our a e departments in school
Scotland are the best performing
anywhere in the UK that's not down to
coincidence or down to chance of course
that's down to the leadership so it's 95
the target when did you last meet it up
well before the pandemic but better July
2020. of course the important point to
mention bill of course that was because
we weren't doing any elective care
that's because we had stopped what
caused uh most of our Energy Services
now how are you doing now in the a e
five percent or 64.9 I think was the
last figure that came out but let me
just make this point Beth well the
context 22 the context of course is that
we've had a global pandemic the biggest
shock that has hit the NHS under my
leadership what have we had the fastest
rollout we've had any waiting times
eight and twelve hour Waits reduced by
almost 50 since the winter Peak and of
course in Scotland not a single member
of the United States
okay talk about the front door let's
take another area of healthcare cancer
treatment discussion government set a
Target 13 years ago that 95 percent of
patients will start treatment within 62
days how's that going have you ever met
that Target again we haven't met the
Target because we're in the midst of a
global pandemic or recovering the
targets yes
have you ever met the target since 2010
you haven't met the target but we're of
course making progress before the
pandemic and the point is that every
single effort is going in to make sure
we recover our NHS from the global
pandemic and that's why to you it's
under the SMP government the Target in
Cancer Care has been missed apart from
one year in 13 years you can't blame
that on the pandemic what's what's the
when it comes to the 31 day Target of
course we have met that Target you're
talking about the 62-day target which of
course is more challenging to suggest
that there hasn't been progress in
meeting those targets I'm afraid
there hasn't been progress been made
so if we accept that the pandemic has
distorted targets and made them hard to
distorted to be a better understanding
okay the biggest shot that the NHS has
faced in 17. all right well let's look
at post-pandemic Targets that you set in
July post-pandemic targets you promised
impatience who've been waiting more than
two years that they should be seen by
the end of September 2022 how many of
them were still waiting by the end of
sept actually if you remember the target
if you've got it there in black and
white it's of course that we would
eliminate weights for the longest
waiters in most Specialties denote
patients we managed to reduce more
Specialties to either 10 people or fewer
people were waiting at the end of 2022.
at the end of 2022 in September it was
7288 but again the target was to
eliminate and more Specialties I'm sorry
you can't just change the goal post Beth
the goal postware and the target was to
eliminate in most Specialties more
Specialties we had 10 or fewer people
waiting when it came to education
288 people okay let's take another final
Target that you set out patients waiting
for more than a year would be seen by
the end of March 2023 so the end of this
month more Specialties most thirty five
thousand people you've got two weeks to
do that will that happen you're going to
hit that Target I'm hopeful that we'll
be able to meet the Target in relation
to most Specialties but of course we
have to also accept that this winter the
winter that just passed has been the
most difficult winter NHS services not
just in Scotland but in England Wales
Northern Ireland interface and I've got
no doubt that will have an impact but I
want to thank our NHS staff for the
incredible work that they've done and
that's why I've made sure they've been
paid fairly and that's of course why
we've avoided a single day of NHS a
single day of strikes in our NHS here
here in Scotland so I put it to you that
if you are a cancer patient there were
Target settings 2010 they haven't been
met in the pandemic the targets weren't
met and in terms of a need they're
nowhere near being met it's 65 isn't it
in terms of the four hour wait and then
in terms of the targets you've set
you're now saying well it's my specialty
so if you don't hit the target then that
was the target episode that was the
Target that I say originally in August
or sorry it was uh the beginning of
summer when I said so when I when I lay
so when I lay all of that out
after all of that you really think that
you deserve a promotion to fast Minister
let's leave that to the SNP members
because what I've done is Health
secretary is roll out the fastest ever
covered booster program okay what I've
done is ensure on our NHS staff have had
to go on strike what I've done is
reduced inpatient outpatient waiting
lists okay the longest waiters by 25 all
right well on our poll the government's
handling of the NHS
30 of people said that you were handling
it well 62 that's indeed two in three
Scots said you were handling it badly so
that's what the public say
again if you look at three weeks ago
when this campaign started I've managed
to quadruple my support amongst the
Scottish public amongst SNP supporters I
was behind I've known 19 points ahead
that's in three weeks if I'm able to
inspire people not just in a few weeks
but in three months I genuinely believe
that we'll not only grow support for our
party but for our independence class
okay thank you if you'd like to return
back uh
okay holds you hinted you might not keep
Mr Youssef in his job the other day has
he changed your mind I think it might be
more than a hint trust trust matters
obviously when it comes to winning
elections and we've just heard about the
Health Service but actually on every
policy area in every single survey of
the public I am more trusted to do a
better job why do you think that is you
I've noticed actually in all of the
polls you've managed to appeal to
conservative voters the most labor
voters don't interrupt you so if you let
me finish no actually in SNP members
you've managed to drop support quite
significantly amongst conservative
supporters so I'm not surprised that
amongst conservative voters and
conservatives I'm not all that popular
I'm a progressive who wants to break up
or you who wants to break up the United
Kingdom but why do you think on policy
areas so we're talking about policy here
it's a good governance matters so a good
Health Service matters dealing with the
economy matters I mean what would you do
to deliver for example economic growth
in our economy and why do you think I'm
more trusted to tackle the cost of
living crazy
I suspect because you've not had a
public service delivery at all but I've
had three of the most difficult in
government over the last 10 and a half
years of course they're challenging
there's no doubt about it and health
secretary in the midst of a global
pandemic on your question on the economy
I think the difference between you and I
is I want to promote a well-being
economy that puts people at the center
that's what I do I want to make sure we
have a minister for small business and
Innovation who works across government I
want to look at every single regulation
that we pass for small businesses and
see what more we can do to ease that
burden on small businesses I've got a
lot more to say about do you do you
think uh future first Minister and
leader of the SNP should appeal to more
than just SMP members and again I go
back to the point of if the public have
seen how you perform why do you think I
am more trusted on every policy area
across the public to deliver I think I
think it's just because you've not had a
public service delivery role in
government I think that's why uh
probably that's probably the reason why
but let me also say I agree with you you
do have to appeal to no voters that's a
fair point to deliver Independence well
it's not the only way because what you
have to do is you have to maintain your
own support and you started this race as
The Bookies favorite The Runaway
favorite well not quite now amongst the
SMP support you've managed to plummet
your support and your ratings have
dropped and yeah and it's so important
that to retain that progress
absolutely the progressive job how are
you going to deliver Independence if the
public don't have confidence in you they
do and for three weeks I've managed to
increase public support quadrupled in
fact now that's what I've managed to do
in three weeks when people have heard my
uh that's what that's that's what the
public have have their confidence in me
in three weeks imagine what I could do
in three months you have improved yeah I
still have the highest net positivity
ratings I'm still more trusted in every
pulse area and when it comes to I don't
know let's take what would you do to
incentivize jobs and uh growth in three
of Scotland's biggest industries well
there's a number of things first of all
I would power our green sector our green
economy I've made the point of course
that I don't just want to lease our
future offshore window I want to make
sure we have a public Equity stake in it
what I'll also do is I'll make sure that
I reduce the burden in small businesses
I also want to invest in Innovation
Scotland's got a great a great
reputation a world-class reputation and
Life Sciences I want to invest more
money into Life Sciences I can go on
give me another five if you want okay
you keep shaking your head yes what
would you like to say to them sounds
like tasks so you've mentioned the
Queensbury Crossing and obviously that's
a very successful major infrastructure
project in Scotland can you explain why
you're claiming credit for your
involvement in that when you actually
had no part in the design of it and
nothing to do the contract Awards or the
building and in fact what you were
responsible for was a six-month delay uh
no actually it came in under budget and
of course I completed the project wasn't
anything I accept and you can sit here
and feel free to attack the snp's record
in the Queen's Philly Crossing I don't
think it's going to do I'm not attacking
the smps I suggested that it wasn't as
successful no I did not say that don't
put words in my mouth let's not let's
interrupt each other I'm answering your
question well you're not answering the
question I've asked you I am I oversaw
the completion of the queen and under
budget yeah
one year from the end of a 10-year
project so I'm asking you so you think
you think I'm not responsible you were
for that project and why Europe the best
well in the world just to suggest that
somebody who's transport Minister as I
was for a year overseeing a major
infrastructure project to think I didn't
have any role in it my role of course is
to make sure
under a budget to criticize the SNP
government for delivering that
phenomenal Queens
I think it's not going to win a support
for Independence it's giving ammunition
I've started my remarks quite literally
by saying that it was a very successful
infrastructure projects
so I'll move on to the NHS public are
obviously very concerned about some of
the issues that we've got in our NHS and
obviously you are currently in charge of
the NHS so did you take responsibility
for that law trust that the public have
in that major and beloved institution of
our NHS look at as leader of the SNP if
I'm elected and as first Minister I'll
always take responsibility because
ultimately of course as cabinet
secretaries that is first Minister we
have to make sure we take responsibility
let me let me let me also say that I
take responsibility for the fastest ever
covered rollout just to roll it I take
responsibility for the fact that not
single day in the NHS has been lost to
strike action I take responsibility for
the fact we were just waiting times for
inpatients and outpatients the longest
weeks by 25 I take responsibility for
the fact that 12 and 808s in a e have
reduced by 40 to 50 since the winter
Peak
but the public are are saying due to the
recent polling that I think what was the
figure 62 saying that you're not you're
not managing it very well so do you do
you take responsibility we are living at
a time where the NHS has faced its
biggest shock for 17. no I understand
that I think that is definitely a factor
yes but what I'm saying is native
Kingdom so yes the NHS is my
responsibility absolutely where it has
done well is my responsibility
I'll finish off with one last question
of course which is you've obviously made
much of your Progressive credentials
during this campaign and we spent quite
a lot of time talking about those type
of issues
um so I'm wondering if you can give some
clarity to the viewers and the S P
members about that missed vote because
there's a couple of different
conflicting ideas about what what may
have happened there to do with the vote
on equal marriage yeah I think it's Alex
salmon the leader of the Alba party who
the arrival party to the SNP who's tried
to cast out on that no I think there is
also people that are in the essence the
leader of Alba who knows people that are
in there and I'm not sure why you bring
that up when I've already answered the
question of course that I was helping to
make sure a Scottish Pakistani who was
in a Pakistani jail on death row for
blasphemy I was making sure I could get
him released of course his family have
said that my intervention was crucial to
that so to drag that up nine years later
in a leadership contest I don't think
reflects very well on you I can
understand why the leader of the Alba
party would do it I'm not sure why a
fellow person has nothing to do without
This was um raised by someone who's in
currently in the SNP
I've given you the explanation if you
want to do Alba's work for them in that
regard their arrival party to the SNP I
don't think that's going to win us
support just said that this is someone
just to be just to jump in there I
actually did that interview with Alex
Summers and he said that his
recollection was that you were asked to
avoid that final vote and he was told
that that was for religious reasons or
religious pressure just to put it on
record that's what he told me on record
in an interview yeah you have said that
that is not
that is not correct but just to clear
that yeah sure it was Alex Simon the
leader of a rival party yeah at the time
he was first married let's we leave it
but just put it on the record that's
what he said on the record you on the
record have said that is not true let's
move on there's now we're going to do
some quick fire questions one of my
favorites I need Snappy answers please
I'm going to kick off uh with a viewer
question and this one is from Terry
Moore and the question is if you win
will you ask advice from Nicholas
sturgeon Ash I'll start with you of
course I would Nicola is a very
successful politician she has been at
the top of her game for many many years
now it's very unusual in politics to be
um in that at that high level for such a
long period so of course I would however
I think she's looking for other jobs
elsewhere so she may not be around for
much longer Snappy answer absolutely yes
she's exceptional
yes but I have to say it will be the
strangest feeling in the world answering
a question from Nicholas dungeon in the
back benches but yes absolutely what
about Alex salmon take advice from him
no no he's in a different party a rival
party so so no so no no no so no one
takes it advice from Alex Simon but all
yes to Nicholas sturgeon let's start off
with you hamsa for this one is JK
Rowling a National Treasure oh yes I
think she's done amazing in terms of the
book she's written but I disagree with
her vehemently on the issue of
transgender rights okay yes and I do
think she's Brave
do you disagree with how on the issue of
transgender rights no I don't disagree
with her you don't disagree that so you
so you back her on that Ash
um I think she's a National Treasure yes
I think she was very brave to speak out
on an issue where many women who had
raised legitimate concerns were
receiving you know quite threatening
Communications so yes she's uh
definitely a national okay and I'll come
chew for us to this one Gary lineker has
been reinstated as a BBC presenter after
the chaos of the last few days should
the director General Tim Davey stand
down well I certainly think he's not
done the BBC any services at a time when
already there is huge debate freedom of
speech is a huge question mark in our
society and I think the whole process
has been managed really badly Ash I
would agree with that I think it has
been managed badly and it has not made
the BBC look in a very good light Tim
Davis stay on go I think he should well
it's up to him he maybe will want to
consider that but it definitely has put
the BBC in um it looks like it's in a
bit of a conflicting position do you
remember given Gary lineker a red card
the other night I did preface it by
saying that I hadn't actually seen the
tweets concerned and I thought it was
something to do with football
okay I'm so what do you think Tim Davis
the guy I genuinely don't think
government ministers acting and current
serving government ministers should be
interfering and who's in charge of our
public broadcaster or not Gary lineker
was absolutely right to make the remarks
he did and it's a heck of a world with
the main opposition is Gary lineker and
Carol vorderman at the moment bit more
power to both their elbows okay final
quick fire I'm going to go to you first
Dash Rishi sunako kirstama who's the
next PM
um I think that it was looking at the
moment that it might be case armor okay
it's highly late there'll be curious
darmer but one zatory and one's a pure
limitation of a story but I'll tell you
what I'll work with anybody to kick out
the Tories well let me come on to this
do you think it's going to be care
starmer though I expect it would be okay
but let's come on to this this is like
the final question now because if
there's an expectation that label will
win the next general election it might
be that they win that by being the
largest party for they don't win an
outright majority you the SMP are the
third biggest party in Westminster you
are if you like the king makers so it's
a very simple question I'm going to
start with you hamster what would be
your price of supporting or propping up
a labor minority government what's the
price give us the power to hold a
referendum because our democracy and our
voice should not be denied any longer so
you want the section 34 to hold you want
the section of that he you won't if I
had a shopping list the next one would
be repeal of section 35 of course which
is used to veto legislation passed by
majority of this so your prices give us
that referendum well we will always say
with fellow Progressive parties you know
I care immensely about independence and
I'll come on to my price but measures
right now to eradicate poverty are
measures that I would wholeheartedly
support and when it comes to any price
of that I think we should be knighted in
eradicating poverty but secondly for
anything more it would need to be
another referendum that that's
interesting though so what your
suggestion is that you would vote with
uh labor on a case-by-case basis in
Westminster depending on the policies
regardless of whether they gave you a
referendum or not it's an interesting
position
never trade poverty and Independence I
firmly believe in working with anybody
who will work with us to eradicate the
fact that one in four children in
Scotland are in poverty but ultimately
any support needs to be contingent on
another referendum okay ashrigan yes I
think obviously if you were going to do
a deal of that kind you would need to
extract something for the the country of
Scotland at the moment we're obviously
in a political stalemate where
Westminster are denying the voice of
Scotland being expressed so a section 30
order would be an obvious way to go
there so in terms of in terms of Labor
though presumably all of you are quite
worried at the moment because it could
be that having had this dominance uh in
Scottish politics for so long that labor
could be enjoying a Renaissance now that
Nicholas sturgeon obviously you're
frowning at me well now but Nicola
sturgeon is standing down that's because
your own poll out today showed that
we've increased support from the last
poll and it shows that labor has fallen
behind so anybody opportunity
as an opportunity let me put it that way
yes but you're impulse was that's not
the case and the reason why is because
we've had that Progressive agenda that's
won us so much support I want to build
on that make sure we don't do so we
won't be complacent what I'll do is I'll
build the team harness all the talent of
the SNP and make sure we deal with the
issues affecting people the cost of
living crisis not reducing poverty or
eradicating it that's what I want to
make sure we do and I don't think we
need to be worried I'm really worried
about this okay we've only got a little
bit of time quick question please the
normal party should take its support for
granted the way that we've won
successive elections is maintaining the
trust that we will stand up for the
Scottish people and that's why I think
in this contest it is about a reset it's
about who can reach out to new voters
even no voters and maintain that winning
Victory when it comes to our elections
quick last word frustration are you
concerned that if another candidate wins
that perhaps isn't as focused on
Independence as you that that you could
lose out I think literally 10 seconds I
think we need not to take our current
support for granted I think we need
fresh leadership that can give people
hope and Inspire them to come out and
vote SNP okay well thank you so much we
are out of time can you believe it went
so quickly thank you so much Kate Forbes
Hamza Yusuf Ash Reagan for joining us
one of them is going to be crowned the
new SMP leader watch it all on Sky News
[Music]
thank you